after more than a decade on the small
screen
amc's zombie horror series the walking
dead
is coming to an end as the network
announced in september 2020 the walking
dead's upcoming 11th season will serve
as its last
airing in late 2022 with 24 episodes
quadruple the amount that its first
season had
the overarching franchise will continue
on with the well-established spin-off
series
fear the walking dead the soon-to-launch
limited series spin-off the walking dead
world beyond
a trio of feature films centered around
former hero rick grimes
another spin-off focused on daryl and
carol and a character-focused anthology
series entitled
tales of the walking dead it's exciting
that the franchise overseen by former
walking dead
showrunner scott m gimple is finding new
life in more and more projects
but there's no denying that the show's
conclusion will mark the end of an era
in total 31 episodes stand between fans
and the end of the walking dead
what might the final episode look like
let's speculate
robert kirkman's long-running walking
dead comic series delivered its final
volume back in late july 2019
when the walking dead was in between its
9th and 10th seasons
as with many page to screen adaptations
the series has deviated from its source
material
changing up certain plot lines and
character arcs
you've been back with us here now
that's everything issues 192 and 193 of
the walking dead encapsulate the ending
of the comics run
and what happens within them would be
impossible to perfectly recreate for the
show because of the changes the series
team made prior to that point
in issue 192 rick meets his end at the
hands of one of his enemies
rick's son carl is sadly the one who
must put
rick's reanimated corpse down for good
the walking dead issue 193
the very last of them all picks up
several years after
those fateful events carl's all grown up
married to a woman named sophia
raising a daughter of his own the final
frame of the comics show adult carl
regaling his daughter with stories of
her grandpa
the brave and noble rick grimes the end
now this exact
finale can't happen on the show for
starters andrew lincoln's rick grimes
isn't around anymore
and hasn't been since season 9 when
everyone believed he died
he was then seen being taken to a safe
place via helicopter
so we know he's still out there
somewhere lincoln could return for the
walking dead finale of course but it
feels more likely that the next place
fans will see rick's face
is in the first of his three standalone
movies then there's the fact that carl
died on the walking dead before his
father left having met a tragic demise
in season eight
while his would-be wife sophia has been
out of the picture since season two
another key player within the comics
finale will also be totally out of the
picture on the show
michonne actress deny guerrera is set to
exit
after season 10. please
don't that considered though a finale
similar to the comics could play out on
the walking dead
rick's daughter judith is still very
much alive on the series
so it's possible she could stand in for
carl on the show's finale
in the same vein michonne and rick also
share
a son r.j who could be the grown-up
fancy telling his daughter tales of the
great rick grimes upon the series end
for his part gimple has said that the
walking dead team plans to adapt
the comics finale the best that it can
and acknowledges that there will be
challenges in the adaptation because the
show
isn't going to kill off rick he also
offered up some remarks that possibly
hint at the series ending
on a positive hopeful note telling
deadline in october 2019
i knew that robert had been working
toward a finale
and he had mentioned some ballpark
aspects but he held back a lot because
he knew
i wouldn't want spoilers the biggest
thing is we will tell
that finale story one day honoring the
aspects of the broader finale story
without the death of rick grimes will be
a challenge to our storytelling
when asked why the walking dead
television adaptation
changed so much from its comic source
material gimple responded that it had a
lot to do with wanting to preserve the
feeling a reader gets when discovering
something in the comic he explained
if robert has a surprise on the page we
might change things on the screen
only so we can get to that surprise in a
way that protected it
so people can't predict it that remains
the job even when the stories are new
and even when stories aren't directly
related to the comic
to capture the spirit of the comic i
always want to feel the spirit of the
book in everything we do
it may not be clear how the walking dead
will end in terms of its characters and
its plot
but one thing seems obvious with gimbal
in charge
fans can rest easy knowing the tv series
conclusion will likely give them the
same fuzzy feelings that the comic book
finale did
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one